herzlich willkommen natürlich freundlich
heute zu einer neuen nicht lachen
challenge auf meinem kanal zusammen mit
mir und sandy hallo du musst jetzt
denken wir schon war einfach der fette
diabetes tust ja schon könig rechten
zeigefinger deshalb nötig
[Musik]
dieser typ von willi wills wissen schon
immer so einfach da ist das noch mal
genau der akteure noch spongebob geguckt
deswegen weiß ich nicht jetzt macht ihr
das auch mit eure mütter und da eben
herum gelegt
[Musik]
ich bin zwar kein wunder aber die
trotzdem was machen wir dann besser
[Musik]
er wird schlag
er soll so ein richtiger book award wird
seit dem richtig kennenzulernen
das ist eine tolle braut sehr schickes
kleid dreh dich mal was ist mit diesem
ja das ist bei vielen serien so dass
also diese ganzen zweideutigen komischen
sachen erst auffallen wenn man nämlich
ein bisschen älter als ich mal war jetzt
als war kleiner waffen immer so yao des
übels der kampfwoche salami malta ein
laufender erlaufen ein laufendes erfolgt
bin ich allein die und eigentlich liegt
safe auf die kamera zu
doch nicht ich hätte einfach auf die
kamera zu welchen bock drauf - nochmal
passiert dann komme ich nie wieder
was ist mit dir nicht mit jim ja das so
eine sache
sandra hat sich jetzt zum thema
angemeldet meiner lieben freund habe ich
ja schon meiner instagram story gepostet
die tage mit premium tageskarte ja es
hat einfach vertrag werde ich werde so
viel erzählen was ich schon mal da
nein deine füße stecken schon ein
bisschen aber nicht mehr so krank nicht
mehr so krass aber jetzt wo sie hier
ziemlich nah sind ist schon was hat die
fans gegeben
ein anti er das bleibt geheim ich sage
nicht ich brauche ist auch nichts mir
scheiß egal ob du mir sagst oder nicht
die leute die es wissen wollen schreibt
mir privat so macht nicht nur den tisch
ist aber der ist nicht richtig
[Musik]
das ist kein staub ist sie haben einen
hat sie dieses thema ist so
mit mikro
wenn ich am kartentisch sitze ist es
kein glücksspiel mit einem kartenspiel
ich sehe genauso bist du auf kleinsten
dach doch ich habe immer pech bei
spielen nein aber nein du bist du bist
so 100 prozent so hör auf diesem tisch
zaubert machen er ist sauber aber unstet
hier in seinem gewissen mächtigkeit
ordentlich daran gearbeitet die sache
jetzt die leute diese minis machen wir
müssen ja so viel material oder
zugesendet bekommen sie sehr unfassbar
wahrheit sagen aha das ist nicht dein
ernst oder
das ist und das ist unglaublich alter
mario also ich sag dir ehrlich was du
machst du hast du schon mal gespielt
nein was ist das
merck dieses licht wilhelm busch merkte
dass nicht erneut treff ist heute
erscheint das risiko durch t shirt
unterwegs spotify datums lästig und doof
ja was eine hamburger kosten der auch
als sowie 20
die preise erhöht es ist nicht euer
ernst musst du eigentlich sagen wenn du
sitzt da direkt an der quelle
cicek ich jetzt nicht die teuersten
früher was sich ein ein euro jetzt 140
mittlerweile etwas anders gemacht
hamburger dieser lang viel sinn für den
streifen da der zehn zentimeter lang ist
ich weiß mein ganzes geld
wissen sie was der unterschied zwischen
mir und nutze ein reporter wissen sie
was der unterschied zwischen ich und du
dich weil wir noch den hier ist doch der
ihr oder nicht was ist denn hier so von
wegen zwei arten von chips essen der
genießer
so lag der stopper christian engl
wenn du abbiegst dann bringt doch
einfach das wasser elvis krieg nicht
gesehen hat wir haben ja nur was
überhaupt so gut wie sicher zu sagen
eigentlich gelernt was heißt denn
kühlschrank englisch kühlstrecke ja was
sprachen lernen
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich ich bin an trocken was ist
es ist nicht gerade warten wir mal
anderes video das ist damit wie die lone
star will wo ich denke wie du meinst du
willst immer noch wissen ob es dort für
kapitän bestimmt genug um zu investieren
der dhc hannover kohler ich liebe es
berlin lebt malone melodien
sprachenlernen melodien 5 6 7 8 9 10 es
heftig
bistum gehe jeden tag ne jura dreck und
gummi um meier
ich find der apa und lecker aber ich
habe die frist kein witzig hat weil ich
fand die extrem lecker aber das laufen
so viel kokos sag mir jetzt bitte nichts
komisch ist sagt ich das ganz gut ich
hab sie abgewaschen
raffaels ausgepackt unter wasserhahn
gehalten und abgewaschen
spielen wir so nicht sagen
und jawohl daraus der bau von der
franziska sozusagen und wir sehen dass
wir jetzt vielleicht der blinden von der
franziska die kinder man sich greifen
mit der guten appetit
willi willi mein beileid bruder ich weiß
nicht was bei dir da falsch gelaufen ist
ich weiß nicht ob also die gleiche sache
ich glaube als kinder man sich gedacht
aha ich will das jetzt auch essen die
dich so lustig meinen vorbildern zeigen
was sie haben wie die britsche es mir
nicht meinen gibst du würde jetzt will
die leute die jungs hatten die leute die
jetzt jungs spielen einfach nur 15
stimmt wie 5 gegen die an der stelle
wollen wir das heutige wieder in meine
lieben freunde sagt der heutige nicht
lachen scheint gefallen hat er lasse
gerne einen daumen hoch und hebe die
daten jetzt soll kein zeitdruck seit und
sandra durch jetzt sechs wörter bevor
das auto kommen die geilste aus
deutschland und jetzt befinden uns auch
von meiner lieben freunde über sandras
kopf befindet sich ein smiley wenn die
da drauf steht könnte meinen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren und unter sanders
kopf befindet ihr ein video und zwar die
letzte nicht lachen challenge von uns ja
schon ein bisschen her
allerdings könnt ihr euch dann noch
anschauen wenn ihr möchtet also klickt
oder auch der andere frösche oder da
würde man hier